let's start with McLaren what do we know
what is actually what discussions have
actually taken place we know that Apple
is currently in talks with McLaren for
some sort of strategic investment this
would mean bringing cash into the
business taking a percentage of the
company and this would allow Apple to
really choose one of two paths that are
currently considering for a car either
building their own or partnering with
another automaker and giving them the
Apple platform by partnering through an
investment with McLaren sort of opens up
the door for a future Apple McLaren
tie-up Lynn motors is interesting this
is a company that we Bloomberg West
actually looked at in 2014 we
interviewed the CEO this is an electric
scooter company why would Apple want a
scooter company after speaking to
multiple people familiar with the
company we learned that they're really
really proud of their patent portfolio
and they have over ten patents specific
to self driving and one of the
components of apple's project heightened
car project is a self-driving system so
this company and their patents combined
with their engineering resources and
people would be able to assist apple
with that specific part and of course
self-driving if you're building a
self-driving car the actual system
behind that is very critical and of all
the car makers out there McLaren is in
electric it's not into mass production
what do you make of of of both of these
potential deals well mcLaren has been
getting moving towards electric and
hybrid technologies so that is part of
the of the picture here but I actually
think this is really interesting because
look I mean Apple is not getting into
cars to be another car company if
they're going to make this giant step
into this very challenging and and
oftentimes intimidating business they
have to be doing it with sort of a fresh
sheet of paper like being able to bring
a new value proposition to really I
think mobility rather than just making a
car I think what both of these companies
you know sort of reflect the fact that
Apple is interested in them shows that
it's looking at this as a long-term
thing I don't think Apple wants to put
its badge on McLaren I don't think Apple
wants to make a version of this
this self-leveling a motorcycle I think
it wants to acquire both patents
intellectual property but also rd
capabilities which is what McLaren
really brings to the table because I
think they want to take a very sort of
high-end cutting-edge approach to
developing their own vehicles whatever
they end up being anneal obviously
there's a lot we still don't know how
are you sizing up this news especially
given that cars in general or a
low-margin business yet we still have no
idea what Apple is actually working on